these are the cookies that you want with
a glass of milk and saturday morning
cartoons i don't know why you're eating
cookies on saturday morning but still
that sounds good to me
hey guys i'm brenda i'm a tasty producer
and i'm here today at tasty studios and
that's because today i will be comparing
chocolate chip cookies homemade versus
store bought so i'm just gonna get my
things ready right here and get cooking
all right
let's get started with the homemade
version
so i was very lucky because our producer
alvin had already made this recipe and
he shared with me his tricks
he says that this is the perfect one
because it mixes the right amount of
white and brown sugar which gives it
that chewy but not too chewy texture
as the dude from men's warehouse would
say you're gonna like the way it tastes
i
guarantee now we're gonna mix it up
basically what you want is to stir these
sugars so much that they turn into this
caramel looking liquid and that's what
we're looking for
and that's the beauty of homemade you
get to add as many chocolate chunks as
you wish
all right so now we're down to tow house
chocolate chip cookie dough and all this
requires is for you to open up the
package and then place the door on the
tray because guess what they even cut
the little squares for you and you're
ready to bake
and if you thought that pre-made cookie
dough it's already easy
you know this is the top of the top
right here because all this really
really requires is for you to open up
the package pick the prettiest girl in
the pack and enjoy
i feel like i know which one's homemade
but i think i'm gonna have to go with
this one it's just like a classic
after school cookie so if i had to
choose one of these cookies that's my
favorite i'm going homemade it's nice
and flat it's perfectly bendy there's
just something about this cookie that
really
these are great totally 100 store bought
but nothing wrong with it because it's
chocolate chip and it's cookies these i
feel like are the kind of cookies you
get at like a bakery or coffee shop
which is awesome like these are like the
cookies that your mom makes when you're
having friends over they're like made
with that touch of love that tlc perfect
chocolate chip cookie perfection my
favorite has to be the homemade one it's
chocolaty it's soft it melts in your
mouth homemade for the win always i love
chips ahoy cookies i just like how
crunchy they are all the way through
it's like dry and crumbly but
in the best way it's chewy but it's not
like doughy or undercooked and the
chocolate it's like when you pull it you
can see the chocolate in it like this is
what i want a chocolate chip cookie it's
pretty clear that it comes down to these
two versions right here
from scratch and pre-made dough the
majority of the people went for the
homemade there's so much love and
chocolate that went into this that i'm
just not surprised at all if you don't
have much time then you can just go
ahead and grab a couple of squares put
them in the oven and 10 minutes later
you got beautiful warm chocolate chip
cookies i also asked people on instagram
based on looks they would go for
homemade from scratch all you have to do
is add 10 more minutes to your schedule
and you can go
from this which is not bad at all to
this which is
50 times better i have to say well
that's my opinion and the amount of
chocolate this is the remedy to all the
problems in your life
just go through this
all right
yeah fingers